so joe biden is ending negotiations with
republicans over the infrastructure bill
and this now puts
the possibility of budget reconciliation
in focus
joe biden got off to a relatively fast
start immediately signing a bunch of
executive orders on doing some of the
nonsense that donald
trump did uh getting the 1.9 trillion
dollar coveted stimulus pass not as
quickly as we would have liked but still
by washington terms relatively quickly
um
and then uh rolling out a very
successful
vaccination program but what is next and
we've been talking about
well if it's not going to be
infrastructure it's got to be something
else that's big but infrastructure
really seems
like the way to go uh joe biden has been
negotiating with uh senator shelly moore
capito
and some other republicans over
infrastructure legislation and cbs news
now reports
that it's over um joe biden has said to
senator capito
that the last republican proposal
doesn't meet the essential needs of our
country to fix roads and bridges
it doesn't prepare the country for a
future that will be reliant on clean
energy
and it doesn't create jobs and this is
according to the white house press
secretary
and so what is now next and
the answer is i don't know when you look
at the details that have been released
of this negotiation that joe biden had
with with house and senate uh lawmakers
um the he reduced his plan
by over a trillion dollars that's a big
concession from joe biden already
and then republicans came up in new
investments
by only 150 billion and this is the
prototypical situation
where you negotiate and you negotiate
and negotiate with republicans
you settle on something in the middle
and then they don't vote for it anyway
so what was all of the negotiation for
now i am not against joe biden doing
some discussion i think it's fine that
he did that
because now he can say we gave major
concessions we sliced a trillion dollars
off of this thing and then they wanted
to give us essentially nothing and so
we're moving on without them
i don't think that that's a waste of
time what
will become a waste of time is now
if they don't simply make this happen
via budget reconciliation
can they actually do that i don't know i
don't know that joe manchin
actually wants the bill the way that it
is and
by the way i mean from an infrastructure
perspective
west virginia is a disaster and by
infrastructure i mean
traditional infrastructure like bridges
and tunnels and roads and this type of
thing uh but
broadband infrastructure healthcare
infrastructure
educational infrastructure and on and on
if there is anybody in the senate who
should be desperate for the biggest
possible infrastructure package it
actually should be joe manchin
but as we talked about yesterday i
wasn't kidding when i said joe manchin
was going to be a problem
and it's not even clear to me that
democrats have the 50 votes
in order to pass this via budget
reconciliation if we step back for a
second
i've gotten emails from people saying is
this something that can be done via
budget reconciliation sometimes
you'll hear some on the left say
joe biden should just do medicare for
all through budget reconciliation first
of all joe biden doesn't support
medicare for all but putting that
aside my best reading of when budget
reconciliation can be used
would not allow it to be used for
medicare for all
that being said there is no question
that budget reconciliation
can be used to pass joe biden's
infrastructure bill
with 50 votes in the senate rather than
the 60 you would normally need
but that's only if you have all 50 votes
from democratic senators
and it's not at this point clear that
joe biden actually does
the new york times also reporting on the
stalled negotiations not really stalled
ended negotiations
saying after weeks of failed efforts to
bridge deep divides the president
pulled the plug turning to a bipartisan
group
to try to salvage a chance at compromise
my question is how long do you keep
going at it from this approach
because you end up with what are
sometimes these
pyrrhic victories where you do so much
damage in the process of negotiating
something that republicans will accept
that you are really compromising on your
ability to pass something that's
substantive
and with the current republicans as we
saw with the covet bill
sometimes you spend all this time
negotiating and they all vote against it
anyway so
my sense is that we're sort of getting
to the end here
uh the new york times writes sort of
pseudo-optimistically
the breakdown did not close off the
possibility of a bipartisan compromise
entirely and the white house signaled
that the president would continue
seeking one
he shifted his focus to a bipartisan
group of centrist senators
who have been working separately on an
alternative calling three of them
personally to cheer on efforts and
encourage them to work with top white
house officials to hammer out a deal but
even if the group can agree on a plan
palpable to joe biden
there's no guarantee enough republicans
would accept it
that that is exactly the point that uh
needs to be considered
how much longer are we doing this with
republicans who you know
it's conceivable that you get i don't
know
joe manchin and mitt romney in a room
and
they come up with something that they
say they would support
but then do you still have 60 votes
or are you put in the position of having
to go through budget reconciliation and
then you're just arguing with your own
side you're arguing with joe manchin joe
listen
we have 49 we need 50. what are you
willing to do for us and this is the
exact i mean
when you talk about the type of partisan
gridlock that sometimes it's bipartisan
gridlock when you talk about
the type of partisan gridlock where the
american people just look at it and say
this is why i am dis i i am
disillusioned about even voting
this is why we have voter turnout of 50
55
at midterms because on the one hand we
understand that every two years we get
to say we don't like the people
representing us in the house of
representatives every four years you get
to say that about the white house every
six years you get to say that about
your senator from your particular state
but then when you see
this stuff where democrats aren't even
all on the same page
the things that republicans and
democrats agree upon they don't have
support for
from the broader party or you end up in
a situation where
even those with the majority in this
case democrats
a slim majority 50 50 with kamala's
tie-breaking vote
um are negotiating against themselves
and will joe manchin vote for it will
cinema
vote for it i get being disillusioned
with the system and this is sort of like
the worst of the worst of the worst of
american politics
i don't know whether this thing's going
to pass if you said you know
take a bet i think 55
45 something passes
how much it will look like joe biden's
initial proposal i have absolutely no
idea but i'm interested in hearing from
you
you do you think this will go anywhere
one of our sponsors is
magic spoon breakfast cereal sweet
and delicious like the cereals we loved
as kids but without the sugar
and without the carbs magic spoon tastes
just like those sugary cereal brands we
know and love
but it's only 140 calories zero grams of
sugar only four net
carbs and packed with 13 to 14 grams of
protein so it's perfect for anyone
following a
keto or low carb diet or just
anyone who wants to avoid sugar like me
you can choose from flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry
cinnamon or build your own variety box
if you don't love magic spoon as much as
i do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked
that is how much magic spoon believes in
their product
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video